- Hi, I'm Sal Khan, founder
of the Khan Academy,
and as you might know, we are
a not-for-profit organization
with the mission of providing
a free world-class education
for anyone, anywhere.
And the way that we're able to do that
is through the support of folks like you.
Khan Academy is much more than me.
We're over 100 people developing the math,
the science, the humanities
content that you've used
and that people that you care
about have used, the SAT prep,
the team that's building
out the adaptive software
and allowing our content and our software
to be localized around the world.
None of that will be possible
without your generous donations.
So if you, or anyone
that you've cared about
has benefited from this, I encourage you,
or I ask that you go to khanacademy.org
and you think about making
a donation of any size.
Any size will help.
And what's especially exciting
is that between now and December 31st,
every dollar you donate will
be matched dollar for dollar
up to $2.3 million.
And so there's a great way
to get a huge return on your donation.
So with that, thank you
for using Khan Academy.
Thank you for supporting Khan Academy,
and I hope you have a wonderful holidays.